I'm pleased to be able to tell you that
Peter hook as you can see is joining us
now here in the studio this afternoon
hello to you it was loud
yeah and I must admit it was fantastic
yeah my son has moved on to better
things I suppose it's the only thing as
a parent that you can hope even though I
miss him greatly from the light I'm
really happy to do that he's with Billy
Corgan he's a nice guy
your kind of music from a half-and-half
I was a little bit shocked actually of
how heavy I remember listening to my
son's bedroom choice Queens of the Stone
Age Metallica pumpkins me telling him to
turn it down all the time I do remember
it was his favorite taste in music yeah
how does that transition from the light
to the Smashing Pumpkins how did that
sort of what happened well I mean
basically jack is a great fun and we
were playing in Chicago and he asked
Billy Corgan along and asked him if he
wanted to sing global tears apart which
Billy did which was wonderful
sorry do you think that's your most
famous song that and blu mondae yeah
without a doubt which is the thing that
really gets people Billy came played
obviously so stout my son was a great
bass player and yelled him from me and
as I say he's just on a 55-day a tour of
America arenas waited on hand and foot
knows what's gonna happen when he gets
to his head of it no no it you know what
he's really level-headed he's a lot more
disciplined he's 29 I think there's a
lot more discipline he's a lot more
studious than me there's nowhere near as
silly shall we say so it was quite the
build-up that well I mean since new
order split up I've never stopped really
having the freedom to do anything I want
there's been wonderful after that
discipline of being in a group
I started playing Joy Division at first
celebrating the music because it was 30
years since Ian died sadly then I moved
into new order this moment well in
committed suicide he was suffering from
epilepsy and it led to
very bad depression and the treatment
product in those days was actually quite
barbaric and I think the thing is is
that the knowledge about the disease was
not very good even people are a lot more
better able and better informed about it
now well nothing you can imagine it
brought Joy Division when they were
really on the cusp becoming all our hard
work over three years was just coming to
fruition when he just couldn't take it
anyone and you know I mean the guilt of
something like that happening to you
stays with you forever anyway any kind
of suicide does that so yeah we we
decided to start again which we did with
new order decision no I didn't want to
go back to work and you know some people
have to work for a living
and playing in a group is pretty good
it's a thing that have got away with it
for 42 years is an amazing achievement
even if I say so myself the freedom it
gives you and shall we say the
expression satisfaction from working for
yourself it did bring his right back
down to kneel it was like snakes and
ladders and I think we didn't in my
opinion we didn't grieve enough for him
at the time because when you're young
you think everyone's going to snatch
everything from you you want to carry on
doing it quickly we should have took her
took our time a little bit longer but we
didn't we threw ourselves into new order
and we made a new order a massive
international success again we were very
lucky you know to do it once was pretty
good to do it twice was amazing what did
you learn from the first time Ryan that
helped absolutely nothing I have to say
we made all kinds of mistakes right
through the eighties the nineties and
yeah I mean you know it's it's an
experience it's a learning experience I
mean just looking at your show there and
looking at the horrors of the world
going on all around us you know a my job
is to get people's mind off that for an
hour and a half three hours a night and
just let's have a bit of levity into
what this world is about you know enjoy
something in it and I think I'm very
lucky for that so tell us what you don't
know well I'm doing now I'm doing The
Joy Division all
arrangement it was interesting I did the
haciendas one that's the Ender classical
which has the nightclub in Manchester
the dance music and the acid house and
we brought it I was skeptical at first
Graham Parker was yes I didn't really
get the correlation how it could be
between dance music and an orchestra
yeah and Graham Park
god bless and he worked on me and we
decided to do it we did it with a guy
called Tim crooks with the who does the
orchestration and runs the orchestra and
lo and behold it did take it to another
level people have grown up with these
songs for a long time
they've been at every important event
throughout their lives and for them to
hear them being performed because most
of the artists were one-hit wonders it
really did to get 70 people performing
that song in front of a live audience
was just amazing in a place like the
Albert Hall is just beautiful songs or
certainly songs in the 80's 90's would
have had a string section when they were
recorded out of a synthesized string
section yeah I mean it was one of the
awakenings for me really when I started
looking into it I realized that we've
been emulating orchestras for a long
long time if you look at a lot of tracks
that new order had hits with like
thieves like us blue Mundi in fact there
are all kestrel arrangements and they're
all orchestral sounds so it's actually
quite logical to go into it what
happened was was that Tim crooks is a
Joy Division fan and he said to me
wouldn't it be a good idea and crossed
my mind still and I thought you know
what yeah because the power that I get
from playing it with the light there's
five people and don't forget Joy
Division never won anyway we had one
trip to Europe before our sad demise
with Ian's
very very sad tragedy so we've not been
anywhere I now take it round the world
I've just been to South America which is
done Mexico Argentina and Brazil playing
Joy Division went down fantastically we
getting crowds of 5,000 6,000 people so
I know that people love the group still
and I'm really you know we're talking
about mental health issues
music is so important when people are
struggling
well I mean I'm not been immune from
that I have their clinical depression
and yes you know I mean it's it's it's
odd to think how many people suffer and
suffer in silence what happened with Ian
was that we were too young to even be
able to contemplate what we should do
and they were very people around him
that were professionals that didn't know
what to do so the thing is is that why
I've learned is that you have to ask for
help and seek it whenever you can and
not suffering silence because
unfortunately Ian was a wonderful human
being and the last thing he wanted was
to put his problems on you so what he
would do was he would always say to you
I'm okay stop worrying everything's fine
you wanted that more than anything in
the world he switched off and of course
he was alone again and I think that
that's the lesson that I've learned is
and there's no people so you have to do
it you have to you know express what's
happening to you what triggered your
clinical depression teeth my divorce
absolutely sadly that was the first time
we met wasn't it yes it was 1995 I was
very impressed I mean it's an easy
traffic's not the year it's not a shock
for people when they go through
something as traumatic as that and yeah
it did
and I must admit it was like falling
into a glass pit that you couldn't find
any way out of and I was treated badly
in that I was prescribed badly and I
ended up having a few friends kicked me
up the booty shall we say but pulled me
back and saved me I have to say yeah it
could have ended very differently yes it
could and I do think that in the back of
my mind you know I've been through it
once with a great friend and colleague
and I knew roughly what was happening
but is still not easy to deal with so
yeah I'm very happy I'm very happy
Caroline had mental health issues as
well yes we were probably a bad
combination at that time very nicely
over when she died it was a challenge
there wasn't it that yes she was a
challenging
but you know love is blind deaf dumb and
stupid so challenging well she was
difficult you know it's I think the
thing is is that the job that we both
did putting yourself right in the firing
line if you like makes everything makes
you sensitive to everything else and it
also makes you vulnerable
you know you're in the limelight you
know and people act differently towards
you and sometimes it's not helpful so no
it was very sad it was very sad and she
was abusive yes how did you deal with
that by not telling anyone who I'm
suffering in silence no and again you
know I learned later many times that
it's not I mean you know as a man it's
it's one of those things they don't like
what the thing is is that I ended up
very ill through it and when I came to
do the book I realized that I didn't
want anybody else to be scared and it's
amazing how many of my close friends
have come to me and said thanks for
saying that because I've never been out
saying it happened to me man
I suppose that's why I'm asking you
about it really the fact that you know
it did happen to you and a lot of people
put you on a pedestal and they think wow
if it could happen to him then it's okay
for me to come forward and say it's
happening to know well it's not fair and
you know the culture that I came from in
Salford in Manchester in the 60s it was
nothing to be proud of and it was very
prevalent so it was horrible you know I
watched my father and do it too my
mother swore that I'd never put up with
it again and when lo and behold you know
I ended up in the same position so it
was a lesson and you know the thing is
is that I do feel now strong enough to
talk about it and to get people to you
know help get help that's the only thing
you can do don't put up with it and you
get help we looking back now I you still
content that you talked about it the way
that she did you did when she died
yes Sam yeah I told the truth and I
think it's very important to tell the
truth what do you say to people who are
trapped in that sort of relationship and
don't know what to do about it
you have to get help there's a lot of
things that can be done with just
phoning somebody Samaritans people like
that you really don't rely on your
friends that's really important yeah I
mean well it's funny that's the hardest
thing to do I mean a lot of my friends
at that point witnessed it and yet you
still didn't feel that you were able to
to talk about it it was something that
you were both embarrassed about you know
and yeah I mean it seems ridiculous now
I have to say at my point in life
looking back and going why the hell how
did that happen
but you know anything like that mental
illness in the same way with E and it
creeps up so slowly so insidiously
all of a sudden you're subject to it and
you don't realize and then you become a
prisoner of it stop making music yes he
did
I I think that it ended up sadly bring
you now alcoholism and drug addiction
which I suffered from I've got a few I
saw help I reach rock bottom and that's
the hardest thing for anybody and I
always say it to people who I see
suffering and they always say to me how
when will it end
you know and it does it gets to a point
when you hit the bottom and you know
it's going to say to you how do you know
when you've hit the bottom
you know believe you me if I hope it
never happens to you but when you know
when you get there and I was convinced
on November the 23rd is 14 years on
November the 23rd and I've been sober
that I thought my life was over when in
reality it was just beginning and I've
achieved more in these 14 years and I'm
a happier person
then I've ever been I'm stronger than
they've ever been so it's funny it's you
know you took that one step think it's
all over and then realize not long
afterwards you know your life is just
beginning what direction you take you
know well I just try to be a good
husband a good father and great musician
there's nothing else I can do really not
thinking about slowing down a bit know
the ripe old age of 62 an hour
no and it was funny I was sat there with
my wife this morning they were saying
I'm booking gigs for when I'm 63 you
know there's something build you know
live fast die young
ethos that Punk had I always bought into
it completely and we lived it in the
eighties and nineties heltah lever in
the Hacienda in Manchester and I never
thought I'd be 63 looking forward we
were very happy all day yeah we've done
very proud to be an ambassador for
Manchester
I've still got a club there the factory
and I have a lot to do with it
on many many levels you know and it's
great I'm very proud of our city very
proud to solve for the Manchester very
tenacious very hardworking people and I
think he's got a great spirit and which
music inspires you my own I have to say
yeah I mean it's music it's funny I rely
on my daughter Jessica she's 20 and we
share iTunes so I get all her music yeah
which is absolutely fantastic so I'm in
the Nutter in the gym on the jogger
screaming away at the top of his voice
where nobody knows what the hell's going
on and who would you say is your
favorite artist at the moment my god now
you're asking that who do I listen to
the most I mean weed Spotify
I'm always looking back it's like it's
funny I was doing an interview this
morning and Roger Daltrey was there so I
can't wait to get on Spotify to put some
who on you know it's these things like
that I mean I I have so much because of
my age that I can listen to I'm very
looking into a lot of dance music as
well just all these I really love Ed
Sheeran I love Ed Sheeran that you know
I love the song he wrote about his
grandeur 'full and the thing is is that
I've been to see him I've been to seeing
small venues thanks to my daughter
yeah yes and I've also been to see him
at Manchester Arena play his capacities
are old and audience yeah he's very
talented I mean I think you know it's
like with any artist you'd like maybe
yourself No
I will I will on your recommendation are
you like Elvis I don't go that far back
but I started in 76 as you said with the
Sex Pistols and funnily enough men made
a lot of friends in music when my great
friends was Dave Dee from dirty [ __ ]
who introduced me to 60s music he
introduced it to me as the ghost of
Christmas future Peter he said so yeah I
mean you know it's amazing after 42
years in the music business and you've
been through a lot which is what was
great sort of help with the three books
writing three books about your life and
the business was fantastic that was the
worst phone call I've ever had well she
was at the ariana grande concert she was
right at the front and she was just
about to get the train home because
there's always that unfortunate thing
with the arena it's such a terrible to
get away from me and words that she was
going to leave yeah ariana came back on
and did the Encore she decided to stay
so she stayed and she was still there
when the bomb went off now my brother's
a policeman and he was telling me that
Ariana Grande's encore saved two
thousand lives well that's what they
reckoned she only played those three
minutes extra two thousand more people
would have been in that for you leaving
and so it was incredible I thought the
woman handle handled herself superb Lee
I think she you know if it was possible
to come out of something well then she
did she really was if such an awful
thing as an artist to think that you
could ever put any of your fans in
danger it's just terrible
so my daughter was trampled in the crush
to get out I thought was badly damaged
she had to go to hospital as one of the
casualties but she was home
and that was the nicest freeway begin to
imagine she suffered terribly from it
over the year and it was funny even
small things like I notice that she
always has to leave a bedroom door on
now she never used to do that before so
you know yeah we do we've talked about a
lot and she went to the concert with me
but when Arianna did the benefit concert
and you know we've tried to exorcise the
demons but you know there's so many
children so many people's children that
I knew who were there that night and
some of them saw much worse things then
Jessica did god bless her so you know
he's terrible when you think I'm looking
you you can be how did you find out and
it had happened and how long from them
to you actually speaking to her she
actually phoned us before it came on TV
because what happened was was that her
boyfriend lives in chalten which is
quite near so we're very very canny she
managed to escape she got onto Deansgate
in Manchester and phoned him his mother
came and picked her up and brought her
to our house she phoned up on the way to
our house and she was actually in our
house before it came on TV so I mean the
the shot was sort of double because of
you had a back which you couldn't
believe and then you were watching it on
the TV
unfold it was just what kind of impact
has it had on the people of Manchester I
think it had a very I mean it's awful to
say healthy it brought people together
in the thing that you know they knew
there was 22 people that weren't coming
home that night which is a terrible
terrible sobering thought for somewhere
like Manchester but I mean I'd go all
around the world I traveled to so many
cities that are ravaged by terrorism
it's just a sad part of life these days
and I think that you know as a musician
it sort of becomes more important that
you go out and let people forget about
that side of you just through about the
difference music can make in people say
yes absolutely in all ways
so yeah it's been it's been a tough
thing to live with watching it you know
I mean what people who lost children oh
my god it doesn't even bear thinking
about and you know I suppose as a
musician you did what you can to help
well we do all the concerts and the
benefit concerts and just making sure
that we do as much as you can you know
it's not it's not difficult things to do
and we do with the Ender as well and we
have done I've got the tattoo I got the
same tattoo daughter on my heel yeah we
both did yeah we went to be together
yeah which really helped yeah now that
there were a lot of the bees that were
on the pavements and stuff actually when
I was up in Manchester when that tragedy
struck and people people didn't know
what the bee was for I mean I know do
you well yeah I mean it's the song for
Manchester the worker bee is the worker
bee the strength because when Manchester
was industrial it's not very industrial
anymore but the the the the symbolism of
them again brought people and it always
makes me laugh cuz I go at the gym a lot
and I see a lot of big guys - there's
gotta be tattoo yeah and you know that
they've been touched
yeah in the same way that you have it's
actually you're quite not it's quite a
thing to think that you know these big
guys and everybody they've all had to go
out and have this mark of respect for
the people and mark of strength for your
city yeah and that's what we have to do
you know as decent people we have to
pull together you get through here I
mean watching your show there you're
dealing with some a musician what would
you've been I always wanted to work in a
scrapyard
my mate used to have a scrapyard in Old
Trafford repairing cars and it was
always my greatest love repairing cars
and tinkering and I always thought I
ended up so maybe I don't know scrap the
odd of musicians Roger Daltrey when I
see him again
do we consider ourselves to be in the
scrapyard of me
there is yes absolutely